[Music]
welcome back
so i've started this video lecture
series on reinforcement learning and the
last three videos were at a very high
level kind of what is reinforcement
learning how does it work uh what are
some of the applications but we really
didn't dig into too many details on the
actual algorithms of how you
implement reinforcement learning in
practice
and so that's what i'm actually going to
do today and in this next part of this
series
is something i hope is going to be
really really useful
kind of for all of you which is the the
first thing is i'm going to kind of
organize the different approaches of
reinforcement learning so this is a
massive field that's about 100 years old
right this merges neuroscience
behavioral science like pavlov's dog
optimization theory optimal control
think
bellman's equation and the hamilton
jacobi bellman equation
all the way to modern day deep
reinforcement learning which is kind of
how to use powerful machine learning
techniques
to solve these optimization problems
and you'll remember that in in my view
of reinforcement learning
this is really at the intersection of
machine learning and control theory so
we're essentially machine learning good
effective control strategies
uh to interact with in a an environment
okay good and so in this first lecture
what i'm gonna do and i think i'm hoping
that this is actually
super useful for some of you
is i'm going to talk through the
organization
of these different decisions you have to
make and kind of how you can think about
the landscape of reinforcement learning
before going on i want to mention um
this is actually a chapter in the new
second edition of our book data driven
science and engineering with myself and
nathan kutz
and reinforcement learning was one of
the new chapters i decided to write so
this is a great excuse for me to get to
learn more about reinforcement learning
and it's also a nice opportunity for me
to kind of get to communicate more
details to you
so if you want to download this chapter
the link is here i'll also put it in the
comments uh below and i'll have a link
to the second edition of the book uh up
soon as well probably in the comments
good so um a new chapter you can follow
along with all of the videos and each
video kind of um you know follows
follows the chapter
good
so before i get into that organizational
chart of how you know all of these
different types of reinforcement
learning can be thought of i want to
just do a really really quick recap of
what is the reinforcement learning
problem so in reinforcement learning you
have an agent
that gets to interact with the world or
the environment through a set of actions
sometimes these are discrete actions
sometimes these are continuous actions
if i have a robot i might have a
continuous action space whereas if i'm
playing a game if i'm the you know the
white pieces on a chess board
then i have a discrete set of actions
even though it might be kind of high
dimensional
and i observe the state of the system at
each time step i get to observe the
state of the system and use that
information uh to change my actions to
try to maximize my current or future
rewards uh through through playing
and i'll mention that in lots of
applications for example in chess the
reward structure might be quite sparse i
might not get any feedback on whether or
not i'm making good moves until the very
end when i either win or lose
tic-tac-toe backgammon checkers go are
all kind of the same way
and that delayed reward structure is one
of the things that makes this
reinforcement learning problem really
really challenging it's what makes uh
you know learning
in animal systems also challenging if
you want to
teach your dog a trick
you know they have to know kind of step
by step what you want them to do
and so you actually sometimes have to
give them rewards at intermediate steps
to train a behavior
and so the agent
their control strategy or their
their policy is typically called pi
and it basically is a probability of
taking action a given a state s a
current state s
so this could be a deterministic policy
it could be a probabilistic policy but
essentially it's a set of rules that
determines what actions i as the agent
take given uh what i sense uh in the
environment to maximize my future
rewards
so that's the policy
and again
usually this is written in a
probabilistic framework because
typically the environment is written as
a probabilistic
model
and there is something called a value
function so given um
you know some policy pi that i take
then i can associate a value with being
in each of the states of this system
essentially by what is my expected
future reward add up all of my future
rewards what's the expectation of that
and we'll put in this little discount
factor because future rewards might be
less uh advantageous to me than than
current rewards this is just something
that people do in economic theory it's
kind of like a you know utility function
and so for every policy pi
there is a value associated with being
in each of the given states s
now again i'll point out for for even
reasonably sophisticated problems you
can do this for tic-tac-toe you can
enumerate all possible states and all
possible actions and you can compute
this value function kind of through
brute force
but even for moderately complicated
games even like checkers
let alone back game in her chess or go
this state space the the the space of
all possible states you could observe
your system in
is astronomically large i think it's
estimated that there's 10 to the 80 plus
um maybe it's 10 to 180 africa it's a
huge number
of possible chess boards even more
possible go boards and so you can't
really actually enumerate this value
function but it's a good um
kind of abstract function that we can
think about are these policy functions
and these value functions
and at least in
simplistic
dynamic programming we often assume that
we know a model of of our environment
and i'll get to that in a minute
so
the goal here the entire goal of
reinforcement learning is to learn
through trial and error through
experience what is the optimal policy to
maximize your future rewards okay so
notice that this value function is a
function of policy
pi i want to learn the best possible
policy that always gives me the most
value out of every board position out of
every state
and that's a really hard problem it's
easy to state the goal and it is really
really hard to solve this problem that's
why it's been
uh you know this growing field for 100
years that's why it's still a growing
field because we have more powerful
emerging techniques in machine learning
to start to solve this problem
so that's the framework i need you to
know what the the policy is that is the
set of kind of rules or or uh
you know controllers that i as an agent
get to take to manipulate my environment
the value function tells me how valuable
it is to be in a particular state so i
might want to move myself into that
state
so i need you to know kind of this
nomenclature so now i can kind of show
you how all of these techniques are
organized
okay so that's what i'm going to do for
the rest of the video is we're going to
talk through kind of the key
organization of all of the different
uh
like like mainstream types of
reinforcement learning
okay so the first biggest dichotomy
is between model-based and model-free
reinforcement learning
so if you actually have a good model
of your environment you have some you
know markov decision process or some
differential equation if you have a good
model to start with then you can work in
this model based reinforcement learning
world
now
some people
don't actually consider what i'm about
to talk about reinforcement learning but
but i do
okay so for example if my environment is
a markov decision process which means
that there is a probability kind of a
deterministic probability that sounds
like an oxymoron but if there is a
specified probability of moving from
state s to the next state s prime given
action a
and this probability function is known
so it's a it doesn't depend on the
history of your actions and states it
only depends on the current state and
the current action determines a
probability of going to a next state s
prime
then uh two really really powerful
techniques that i'm going to tell you
about
to optimize the the policy function pi
is policy iteration and value iteration
these allow you to essentially
iteratively walk through
um the game or or the markov decision
process taking actions that you think
are going to be the best and then
assessing what the value of that action
and state actually are and then kind of
refining and iterating the policy
function and the value function
so that is a really really powerful
approach if you have a model of your
system you can run this kind of on a
computer and
and kind of determine learn what the
best policy and value is
and this is kind of a special case of
dynamic programming that relies on the
bellman optimality
condition for the value function
so i'm going to do a whole lecture on
this blue part right here we're going to
talk about policy iteration and value
iteration and how they are essentially
dynamic using dynamic programming
on the value function which satisfies
bellman's optimality condition
now that was for probabilistic uh
processes things where maybe you know
like backgammon where there's a dice
roll
at every turn
for deterministic systems like a robot
system or a self-driving car if i think
about a human you know my reinforcement
learning problem this is much more of a
continuous control problem
in which case i might have some
nonlinear differential equation x dot
equals f of x comma u and so
the linear optimal control that we
studied i guess in
chapter 8 of the book so linear
quadratic
regulators common filters things like
that optimal linear control problems
are special cases of this optimal
non-linear control problem
with the hamilton jacobi bellman
equation again this relies on bellman
optimality and you can use kind of
dynamic programming
ideas to solve optimal nonlinear control
problems like this
now i'll point out
mathematically this is a beautiful
theory it's powerful
it's been around for decades and it's
you know kind of the textbook way of
thinking about how to design optimal
policies and optimal controllers you
know for markov decision processes and
for non-linear control systems
in practice actually solving these
things with dynamic programming
ends up
usually amounting to a brute force
search
and it's usually not
scalable to high dimensional systems
so typically it's hard to do this
optimal hamilton jacobi bellman type
non-linear control
for an even moderately high dimensional
system you know you can do this for a
three-dimensional system sometimes a
five-dimensional system maybe
you know i've heard special cases with
with machine learning you can do this
maybe for a 10 or 100 dimensional system
but you can't do this for the nonlinear
fluid flow equations which might have
you know a hundred thousand or a million
dimensional differential equation when
you write it down on your computer
so important caveat there
but that's model based control
and a lot of what we're going to do in
model free control
uses ideas
that we learned from model based control
so even though you know i don't actually
do a lot of this in my daily life with
reinforcement learning most of the time
we don't have a good model
of our system
for example in chess i don't have a
model of my opponent for example or at
least i can't write it down
mathematically
as a markov decision process
so i can't really use these techniques
but a lot of what model free control
reinforcement learning is going to do
is kind of approximate dynamic
programming where you're simultaneously
learning kind of the dynamics or
learning to update these
these functions through trial and error
without actually having a model
and so in model-free reinforcement
learning kind of the major dichotomy
here
is between
gradient-free and gradient-based methods
and i'll tell you what this means in a
little bit but for example
if i can parameterize my policy pi by
some variables theta
and i know kind of what the dependency
with those variables theta are i might
be able to take the gradient
of my reward function or my value
function with respect to those
parameters directly and speed up the
optimization okay so gradient based if
you if you can use it is usually going
to be the fastest most efficient way to
do things
but oftentimes again we don't have
gradient information we're just playing
games we're playing chess we're playing
go
and i can't compute the derivative of
one game with respect to another that's
hard for me at least to do
and so within gradient free okay there's
a lot of dichotomies here there's a
dichotomy of a dichotomy of a dichotomy
within gradient free control there is
this idea of sometimes you can be off
policy or on policy
and it's a really important uh
distinction what on policy means
is that let's say i'm playing a bunch of
games of chess
i'm trying to learn an optimal policy
function or an optimal value function or
both by playing games of chess and
iteratively kind of refining my estimate
of pi or a v
what on policy means is that i always
play my best game possible whatever i
think the value function is and whatever
i think my best policy possible is i'm
always going to use that best policy
as i play my game and i'm going to
always try to kind of get the most
reward out of my system every game i
play that's what it means to be on
policy
off policy means well
maybe i'll try some things maybe maybe i
know that my policy is suboptimal and so
i'm just going to do some like random
moves occasionally that is called off
policy because i think they're
sub-optimal but they might be really
valuable for learning information about
the system
uh so on policy methods include this
sarsa state action reward state action
and there's all of these variants of the
sarsa algorithm this on policy
reinforcement learning and these tds
mean temporal difference and mc is monte
carlo and so there's this whole family
of kind of gradient-free optimization
techniques that use different kind of
amounts of history i'll talk all about
that that's going to be a whole other
lecture is this this red box gradient
free
model free reinforcement learning
and so the off policy version of sarsa
kind of this on policy
set of algorithms there is an off policy
variant
called q learning
and so this quality function q is kind
of the
joint value if you like of being in a
particular state
and taking a particular action a
so this quality function contains all of
the information of my my optimal policy
and the value function and both of these
can be derived from the quality function
but the really important distinction is
that when we learn based on the quality
function we don't need a model for what
my next state is going to be this
quality function kind of implicitly
defines the value of you know based on
where you're going to go in the future
and so q learning
is a really nice way of learning when
you have no model
and you can take off policy information
and learn from that you can take a
sub-optimal controller just to see what
happens and still learn and get better
policies and better value functions in
the future
and that's also really important if you
want to do imitation learning if i want
to just watch other people play games of
chess
even though i don't know what their
value function is or what their policy
is
with these off policy learning
algorithms you can accumulate that
information into your estimate of the
world and every bit of information you
get
improves your quality function and it
improves the next game you're going to
play
so really powerful and i would say most
of what we do
nowadays you know is kind of in this q
learning world a lot a lot a lot of
machine learning is q learning
reinforcement learning is q-learning
and then the gradient-based algorithms
i'm not going to talk about it too much
here but it's essentially where you
would actually update the parameters of
your policy or your value function or
your q function directly
using some kind of a gradient
optimization so if i can sum up all of
my future rewards
and it's a function of the current
parameters theta that parameterize my
policy
then i might be able to use gradient
optimization things like newton's steps
and steepest descent things like that to
get a good estimate and this when i have
the ability to do that is going to be
way way faster uh than any of these uh
these gradient free methods and and even
in term uh will be faster than dynamic
programming and so the last piece of
this is kind of in the last 10 years
we've had this massive explosion of deep
reinforcement learning
a lot of this has been because of deep
mind and alphago
you know demonstrating that machines
computers can play atari games at human
level performance they can beat grand
masters that go
just incredibly impressive
demonstrations of reinforcement learning
that now use deep neural networks
either to learn a model where you can
then use model-based reinforcement
learning or to represent these kind of
model-free
concepts so you can have like a deep
neural network for the quality function
you can have a deep neural network for
the policy and then differentiate with
respect to those network parameters uh
using kind of you know auto diff and
back propagation
uh
to do gradient based optimization on
your policy network
i would say that deep model predictive
control this doesn't exactly fit into
the reinforcement learning world but i
would say you know it's it's morally
very closely related deep model
predictive control allows you to solve
these kind of hard optimal nonlinear
problems and then you can actually
learn a policy
based on what your model predictive
controller actually does you can
essentially kind of codify that model
predictive controller into a control
policy
and finally uh actor critic methods um
actor critic methods existed long before
deep reinforcement learning but nowadays
they have kind of a
renewed interest uh because you can you
can uh you can train these with with
deep neural networks
okay so that is the mile-high view
as i see it
of the different categories of
reinforcement learning
is this comprehensive absolutely not is
it a hundred percent factually correct
definitely not
this is you know a rough sketch of the
main divides and things you need to
think about when you're choosing a
reinforcement learning algorithm if you
have a model of your system you can use
dynamic programming based on bellman
optimality if you don't have a model of
the system you can either use gradient
free or gradient based methods
and then there's on policy and off
policy variants depending on you know
your specific needs
it tends out to be that sarsa methods
are more conservative
and q learning will tend to converge
faster
and then for all of these methods there
are ways of kind of making them more
powerful and more
flexible representations using uh deep
neural networks in kind of different
focused ways
okay so in the next few videos we'll
zoom into you know this part here
for markup decision processes how we do
policy iteration and value iteration
we'll actually derive the quality
function uh here
we'll talk about model free control
these kind of gradient free methods on
policy and off policy
cue learning is one of the most
important ones and temporal difference
learning
actually has a lot of neuro
science analog so how we learn in in our
animal brains
people think you know is very closely
related to these td learning policies
we'll talk about how you do optimal
nonlinear control with the hamilton
jacobi bellman equation
uh we'll talk very briefly about policy
gradient optimization and then you know
all of these there are kind of deep
learning things uh we'll pepper it
throughout with deep learning or maybe
i'll have a whole lecture on on these
deep learning methods so that's all
coming up really excited to walk you
through this thank you